Welcome back to the computer screen. We're
going to press on now and we're going to
be looking at the next stage of the PTM.
We're going to be looking at predicting
economic growth. And we're going to be
looking at leading indicators. So we're
getting into the meat of the PTM video
series now.
Get your concentration to the maximum
level because we've got a lot of detail
and this is a big, big video. Video four,
leading indicators one, real interest
rates and the yield curve. Now, if you
haven't seen in the downloads area, we do
have some resources that accompany the
video. We're going to be looking at bonds
and interest rates in this video.
And we have a PDF download and Excel files
that you should be downloading. Probably
best before you go through this video to
download the PDF and go over the bond
market and interest rates basics. Okay.
It's in the downloads area, the downloads
section for the video.
Best to read it, best to read it, best to
read it, best to read it, go over it
before going through this video. Okay. We
also have spreadsheet files that accompany
the video.
So download those. You'll be using these
throughout the video and after the video
to fully understand bond markets and
interest rates. And you'll be using those
spreadsheet files in the future on a
continuous basis.
To keep on top of bond markets and
interest rates. So obtaining a
macroeconomic view. We had a look at that
in the last video where we looked at GDP.
So in the previous video, we analyzed GDP
and why it's important to attempt to
forecast it.
And why it's important to attempt to
forecast it. Why? Because we're attempting
to forecast expected future company
earnings and stock market direction.
However, when we are forming a
macroeconomic view. We shouldn't only view
it through the lens of economic growth
purely. Okay.
We have to view it through the lens of
both growth and liquidity. Now we're going
to be looking a lot throughout the video
series at a metric called PE, the PE
ratio.
PE, the PE ratio, price earnings ratio.
And every stock market has a PE ratio.
We'll get into this in a lot more detail
later in the video series.
The stock market PE, when we're looking at
it, it's generally true to say that whilst
economic growth drives the denominator,
the E in the PE,
liquidity drives the P, which is price. So
PE is the price of an asset divided by
earnings. So the price of a stock divided
by earnings.
But the stock market has its own earnings.
It's the total earnings of the stock
market. And the stock market has a price.
It's the price, the level of the stock
market.
Okay. So every stock market has a PE. And
economic growth drives the E in the PE
ratio. Liquidity drives the P.
So it's very important to understand this.
When we are attempting to obtain a
macroeconomic view, it's very important to
not just look at this through the lens of
growth, through the lens of economic
growth.
We have to understand that liquidity is a
factor. Growth drives earnings. Liquidity
drives prices. When liquidity is abundant,
it's cost. So the cost of liquidity is
cheap.
When liquidity is scarce, it's cost is
high. It's expensive. Now, these terms
cheap and expensive, we should always be
careful when we're using these terms,
because cheap and expensive, as you'll
realize later in the video series, is
highly subjective.
Okay. But in general terms, when liquidity
is abundant, so it's in high supply,
liquidity is cheap. It's low priced. When
liquidity is scarce, its cost is high.
It's expensive. It's high priced. Okay.
Abundant liquidity drives prices of
financial assets higher. Okay. And scarce
liquidity puts downward pressure on asset
prices, including the stock market.
So in general terms, guys, when there's a
lot of liquidity in financial markets,
this is a good thing. It's good for
financial assets.
When liquidity dries up. When liquidity
dries up. When there's very little
liquidity. This is a bad thing for
financial markets. Financial markets tend
to go down when there's a lack of
liquidity or liquidity dries up. Financial
markets tend to go up when there's an
abundance of liquidity.
So prices going up when there's an
abundance of liquidity. So prices going
down when liquidity dries up and is
scarce. It is very important to understand
these concepts and ideas as we're building
up our knowledge of financial markets and
building up our understanding of bonds and
interest rates and their effect on stock
markets.
As leading indicators. So let's have a
look at bonds and interest rates. As
equity traders and portfolio managers,
it's really essential for us to know
what's going on in the bond markets all
the time on a regular basis.
What you'll find is generally speaking, is
that typically retail traders and even a
lot of professional traders really pay
absolutely no attention to bond markets
and interest rates. Or if they do, it's a
superficial interest.
Very little attention is given to bonds
and interest rates. Why is this? Well,
it's usually down to a lack of confidence,
a lack of confidence in their ability to
just be able to learn the details of how
bond markets work and how they actually
affect equities markets and equities
portfolios.
Now, we don't need to be absolute experts
on bond markets. Okay. We do, though, need
a generalist understanding and
appreciation for how money is priced, how
the money markets work. Okay.
Because the real and relative price or
cost of money also impacts other asset
classes like equities, currencies and
commodities.
Now, this is a new term that we brought in
here, the price and cost of money.
What are we talking about here? Well, when
we refer to the price or cost of money,
we're referring to interest rates. Okay.
And governments and corporates borrow
money at or above the prevailing market
interest rate.
The price of money is firstly set by the
wholesale money markets. And then
secondly, by the banking sector, which
determines the cost of loans in the
private market. Okay.
Now the level at which interest rates
clear has an impact on equities as an
overall asset class.
So index values, the stock market itself
trades due to macroeconomic factors of
relative value between equities and bonds.
And individual stocks, so individual
equities within the stock market, their
valuations are down to macroeconomic
factors driving relative asset class
valuations plus microeconomic factors that
are idiosyncratic to the company itself.
Such as, for example, the size and cost of
an individual's, an individual company's
debt.
Of course, there's other microeconomic
factors as well that are idiosyncratic to
a company.
Understand the general concept here.
The stock market in its entirety is
affected by macroeconomic factors of the
relative value of equities and bonds,
which is driven by interest rates. Okay.
The stock market in its entirety and
liquidity.
The stock market is just a collection of
all of those stocks.
Now let's continue to try and understand
here interest rates and the price or cost
of money.
When a central bank adjusts interest
rates, they are fully intending to change
the price of money, the cost of money.
When a central bank adjusts interest
rates, they are fully intending to change
the price of money, the cost of money.
In an economy that requires stimulus, say
in the form of investment and consumption,
central banks look to reduce interest
rates and in order to moderate inflation
or prevent excess demand, they look to
increase interest rates.
This basic approach from central banks is
called conventional monetary policy.
They are using interest rates to stimulate
or cool down the economy.
Now, depending on where you are in the
world, central banks, we have different
central banks across the world and we have
different terms used for interest rates.
So, depending on where you are, the
official rate in the US is known as the
Fed Funds Rate, that's from the central
bank, the US Federal Reserve.
In Europe, it's known as the MRO, the Main
Refinancing Operations, that's the ECB,
the European Central Bank.
And for example, in the UK, if we just
take one randomly somewhere else in the
world, the interest rate set by the Bank
of England is known as the base rate.
They're all trying to achieve the same
outcome to manipulate the economy.
It's to set the rate expressed as an
annual percentage rate that banks can lend
out or borrow at overnight.
Effectively, what they're doing is they
are setting the price of money, the cost
of money, which ideally then flows through
to the real economy via the distribution
channel of the banking sector, more
specifically via bank lending.
Now, there are official rates and market
rates.
So, whilst central banks themselves set
the official interest rate, there's an
abundance of many and varied markets for
bonds, notes, wholesale money.
They are collectively known as the market,
collectively setting market interest
rates.
Now, we're going to concentrate on the
United States here because that's what
we're interested in mostly.
We are interested in the US and
forecasting US economic growth, GDP and
liquidity in US financial markets.
So, we'll be focusing exclusively here on
the US.
The 10-year Treasury note rate is the rate
or price and cost at which the US
government can borrow money over 10 years
and is considered by the private market as
a benchmark rate.
What do we mean by benchmark rate?
Everything is priced off this rate in the
private market.
Okay.
The US 10-year Treasury bond, it's the
world's most liquid and widely traded
non-derivative debt instrument.
And the interest rate or the yield on the
10-year Treasury bond is known as the
10-year yield.
So, as a open quotes benchmark, close
quotes, it's used by the private market as
a reference, if you like, a reference
point to price risk, to price bonds, notes
and wholesale money in the private market.
Now, in the US, the US Federal Reserve,
the central bank in the US is the lender
of last resort.
And the US government globally is
considered to be the safest borrower in
the world because the US government has
historically never defaulted on its debt
obligations.
And we put the word safest in quotations
there because safest is a perception.
It's subjective.
Okay.
So, there are reasons for that.
The US Treasury market is the world's
deepest and most liquid market.
Okay.
These securities often serve as collateral
for the global financial system itself and
are all denominated in US dollars, the
world's reserve currency.
Now, the yield on the US 10-year Treasury
note is set by the bond market and it
represents a benchmark from which all
other financial instruments are priced.
And they're priced by spreads.
So, a spread over the 10-year.
So, they're priced higher than the 10-year
Treasury itself.
And these spreads over the benchmark are
used to price corporate bonds, swaps,
mortgages, fixed-rate loans, wholesale
money.
It's collectively the private market.
Okay.
Rates on these products clear in the
market according to the risk of the
borrower.
And that's foreseen by the lender
themselves and set at a premium to the
benchmark.
And it's just a basic approach, guys,
right?
Higher risk is higher rates.
Lower risk is lower rates.
So, a lender, if they see someone as high
risk or see a company as high risk,
they're going to have a higher rate.
So, a much larger spread over the 10-year
Treasury note, the yield, the 10-year
benchmark.
And if a lender sees a company as lower
risk, then a lower rate or tighter spread
is going to be given to that borrower by
the lender.
So, higher risk is higher rates.
Lower risk is lower rates.
Now, we can also have a look at the
visuals of official rates.
This is the United States.
So, the Fed funds rate, the effective
federal funds rate, as set by the Federal
Reserve, the U.S. Federal Reserve.
And we had a brief look at this in the
previous video when we were looking at
correlations between GDP growth and S&P
500 returns.
So, from left to right, we're looking at
the official rate since the early 1950s
all the way up to 2020.
And you can see we have a big rise in
rates all the way to the peak in the
1980s.
And then since the early to mid-80s, we
have the Fed funds rate, the official
rate, dropping continuously to the point
now where we're essentially at zero.
So, we are at zero official rate, okay?
Now, of course, we've had these blips in
between where rates have gone up.
So, in the late 80s, in the mid-90s, in
the late 90s, in the mid-2000s, and more
recently, in the mid-teens.
Of course, we've had these blips where
rates have gone up.
But the official rate in the last 35 years
or so has been on a consistent and steady
decline.
If we look at some other areas of the
world, the story is not any different.
So, if we look at the MRO, the main
refinancing operation from the ECB since
the late 90s, we'll see a similar story
start to take shape around 2008, where
interest rates peak.
And then they've just come down
continuously and now they're at zero.
We can also look at the Bank of England
official base rate.
The base rate, similar situation.
We get more data there than Europe because
the Eurozone ECB is not that old.
But similar to the US data, we can go back
to the 50s, it exhibits a very similar
shape.
So, going up continuously until around the
mid-80s and then dropping continuously
since the mid-80s for around 35 years ago,
down to the current level of essentially
zero.
Now, let's have a look as well at the US
government debt, the 10-year government
treasury yield, which the bond market
prices off official rates.
So, the private markets, the private bond
market pricing off official rates.
Of course, we see a similar situation.
This data, by the way, and this
spreadsheet is available in the downloads
area and you can update that continuously
going forward yourself.
But again, same story since the early
mid-80s, just continuous decline in the
10-year government treasury yield.
And we're going to introduce you here to a
shorter term bond, shorter term US
government treasury bond, the two-year
sovereign bond for the US.
So, there's different maturities in the
bond market for the US government.
And we've so far only looked at the
10-year, but the two-year government bond
exists as well.
And we're essentially looking, when we're
looking at the 10-year bond, we're looking
at longer term yield, longer term rates.
And when we're looking at the two-year
bond, we're looking at shorter term rates.
And again, you can see here, we're
exhibiting the same decline in rates since
the mid-early 80s.
Now, a little bit later in this video, we
are going to be looking at the
relationship between the 10-year and the
two-year.
And we're going to start looking at and
understanding the relationship between
long term and short term money in the bond
market as an indicator of risk and also as
a leading indicator.
But in the meantime, we have to continue
building knowledge and understanding of
the bond market and interest rates.
And there's a big market outside the US
called the Euro-dollar market.
Euro-dollars refer to any US dollars held
outside the US banking system.
And the term Euro-dollars doesn't just
mean geographical location, but US dollars
held by foreign or overseas banks.
There can actually be Euro-dollars held in
any country outside the US by banks
outside the US banking system and by US
banks themselves, but overseas.
Now, the Euro-dollar market was
established after World War II and the
Marshall Plan.
When countries like Germany, France,
Belgium, UK, that were devastated from the
war, began recovering and growing their
economies by trading US dollars.
And they were trying to build back their
economies and build back infrastructure.
In many, many cases, countries preferred
not to repatriate dollars back through the
US banking system.
And what they did was they chose to hold
the US dollars offshore, primarily in
London-based banks.
And from that market, a bank lending
market matured over time around the
collateral.
And the market lending rate of that market
became known as the London Interbank Offer
Rate or LIBOR.
Now, the Euro-dollar market is extremely
important.
It's a huge market because it's the
liquidity of US dollar lending in the rest
of the world outside of the United States.
And the Euro-dollar rate, LIBOR, the
London Interbank Offer Rate, is priced off
the official rate in the United States as
the benchmark.
So you can see how it's very important,
official rates in the United States.
Very important how they are referenced,
not only in the United States, but in the
rest of the world.
So the way it works in practice, banks
holding US dollar deposits outside the
United States in the rest of the world
reference the three-month LIBOR rate,
which is priced off and referenced from,
most typically from the three-month US
Treasury rate.
That spread is commonly known as the TED
spread.
And the three-month US Treasury rate in
the private market is priced off the
official rate, the official base rate.
So you can see how throughout the global
financial system, throughout the global
banking system, everything leads back to
the official base rate in the United
States.
Companies and governments outside the
United States, in the rest of the world,
when they're borrowing in US dollars, the
lender is referencing off these rates.
That's how important it is.
It ripples all the way through from the
United States across the rest of the
world.
Now, the LIBOR, three-month LIBOR rate is
referenced by one of the most liquid and
most traded instruments on the planet, the
Euro-dollar futures contract.
Euro-dollar is essentially a time deposit
product, Euro-dollar futures, where it's a
bank deposit with a rate of interest at
the end of the three months.
The bank deposit is priced off $1 million
in terms of the size of the deposit.
So $1 million deposited in a bank account
outside the United States and the futures
contract written on that for the value of
the $1 million.
Marked at the interest rate at the end of
the three months.
It's one of the most liquid instruments
traded on the planet and therefore
extremely important.
And you can see now as well that the
Euro-dollar futures contract linked to the
three-month LIBOR, linked to three-month
US Treasuries, linked to the official base
rate in the United States.
You can see how all of this is connected
and how the rest of the world depends
extremely heavily on the US dollar and the
liquidity and health of the US Treasury
and bond market and also US yields and
rates.
You know, it is often stated that when the
US sleazes, the rest of the world catches
a cold.
This is very true in the bond markets.
When liquidity is abundant in US bond
markets, the rest of the world has
liquidity.
When liquidity dries up in the United
States, the rest of the world is in
trouble.
And this is why it's so important to
obtain a macroeconomic view, not just of
the US, but of the rest of the world.
This is why it's so important to
understand what is going on in US bond
markets.
But what about issuers and buyers of
bonds?
Who are they?
Well, the issuer, the definition of issuer
in the United States, for example, for a
government bond, is the United States
Treasury.
They are financing their spending or
outgoings of the US government.
So the US Treasury issues a government
bond.
And the private market invests or lends
that money to the US government.
And the US government is using that money
to finance government spending.
Now, the buyers of government bonds, the
entities that are investing or lending
money to the US government.
The buyers of government bonds are pension
funds, mutual funds, hedge funds,
investment banks, commercial banks, even
individuals and even other countries.
Central banks.
And they are traded.
Debt securities trade over the counter, or
in short, OTC.
They're not like equities, where equities,
stocks and stock instruments trade on
exchange.
Bond futures, like Euro dollars, futures
contracts, do, however, trade on exchange.
And it's important to understand these
dynamics because as traders and portfolio
managers, when we're seeking information
from the bond markets for the outlook of
economic growth and liquidity.
What we need to really understand is money
flows.
And money flows are very, very important
in the context of government bond markets.
But let's have a look at the world's
largest and most liquid bond markets just
to understand this globally.
The US Treasury market, by far the biggest
denominated in US dollars.
The European government bond market
denominated in euros.
UK gilts denominated in pounds, British
pounds.
And the Japanese government bonds, JGBs,
that market denominated in yen, Japanese
yen.
There's also peripheral markets globally,
such as Switzerland, Germany, Italy,
Canada, Australia, New Zealand and various
emerging market countries in regions like
Latin America, Asia, Eastern Europe and
Africa.
Now, just to give you a sense of the size
of US bond markets.
US bond markets make up almost 40 trillion
dollars in value.
And when we compare this to the stock
market, domestic stocks in the US
represent around 20 trillion dollars in
value.
In terms of daily trading volume, so
liquidity.
The daily trading volume in bonds in the
US is around 700 billion dollars per day.
This is basically around three and a half
times the size of the stock market volumes
in the US.
Clearly, market rates are a very important
factor and a very efficient indicator of
relative value for other financial
instruments.
Now, if we're going to understand how the
bond market affects equities,
we need to look at it in the context of a
business cycle, an interest rate cycle, a
credit cycle.
Let's have a look at a typical cycle.
Let's start from the very top.
Where we look at the beginning of an
economic growth boom.
What tends to happen?
What actually happens when this occurs?
Well, money becomes cheap.
Okay.
Money becomes low priced and we get an
increase in liquidity.
Okay.
Prices start to move.
The cost of money, the price of money
becomes relatively cheap or cheaper than
before.
What happens?
The economy starts moving.
Governments, companies and individuals
borrow more of it.
We enter a phase of high growth.
So we get higher growth prospects, lots of
consumption and investment.
What happens to equity market, stock
market valuations?
We get higher equity market valuations and
higher earnings.
And then what happens?
In response to that, money becomes more
relatively expensive than before.
Money becomes higher in price.
It becomes more expensive.
And then we have an end to the economic
cycle where the economy resets to an
equilibrium level.
And then we begin again.
Money becomes relatively cheaper and we
enter another high growth phase.
But when we look at this cycle, obviously
through this mechanism, companies are very
important because they are the engines of
driving higher growth.
Individuals are consumers.
Companies are investors.
Companies are driving growth.
If we're going to understand how bond
markets really affect growth and company
earnings, let's understand what the
risk-free rate is.
There are several proxies for the
risk-free rate, but here we are going to
use the 10-year U.S. Treasury note rate.
It's the most widely tracked government
debt instrument in finance and it's the
main benchmark.
As mentioned previously, the yield of the
10-year Treasury bond is often used as a
benchmark for the market to set other
interest rates, such as corporate bonds,
swaps, mortgages, et cetera, and fixed
rate loans.
So, we are going to use the risk-free rate
and we're going to use the benchmark of
the 10-year U.S. Treasury note.
That is going to be our risk-free rate
going forward.
So, what does this mean for companies and
company earnings?
Well, a very important formula used by
equity markets to value companies is the
discounted cash flow formula.
And if you look at the formula here, the
DCF, the discounted cash flow, the present
value of all future cash flows is the DCF.
And in the formula on the top, you can see
cash flow one, cash flow two, cash flow
all the way out to infinity in the future.
And you can see the discount factor of
those cash flows is one plus the risk-free
rate to the power of the period.
Okay.
Now, what happens here?
Well, if we have a lower discount factor,
so the R, the risk-free rate, if we have a
lower discount factor, this gives us a
higher present value.
We have a higher value for the DCF number.
So, we're getting a higher present value
of all future cash flows.
A higher discount factor gives us a lower
present value of all future cash flows.
So, the risk-free rate, which is priced by
equity markets, it's used by equity
markets and priced off the benchmark.
And here we're using the 10-year Treasury
note rate, is a crucial factor in equity
markets for valuing stocks and the stock
market itself.
So, this is how it links together.
Now, we brought it up earlier.
Very, very important.
Price-Earnings Ratio.
It is the most widely used valuation
measure of an equity index.
The price of the S&P 500, for example,
divided by the EPS of the S&P 500 is the
price-earnings Ratio of the S&P 500.
So, we're looking at the level of the S&P
500 and dividing it by the earnings per
share of the S&P 500.
When all things being equal, real interest
rates are close to or even less than zero,
the S&P 500 commands a higher PE valuation
multiple because future earnings
expectations are discounted back by the
market to a higher present value.
Now, the risk-free rate is a subjective,
yet a fundamental driver of equity
valuation when we're using DCF analysis.
As we go through that interest rate cycle
that we looked at earlier, equities get
repriced higher and lower according to
where real interest rates are trading.
And we'll get on to the definition of real
interest rates in a second.
We absolutely need to know, as traders,
the macroeconomic conditions for real
interest rates and central bank intentions
around setting interest rates and real
interest rates.
Now, as you're probably aware, over the
last decade, central banks have been
intervening in the bond market and the
action is they've been buying bonds to
artificially keep both nominal and real
rates low in order to provide liquidity
and inflation to prolong the expansionary
part of the cycle.
By expanding nominal and real GDP growth.
This in itself also causes equity market
valuations to remain at elevated levels.
Now, we're not going to be covering the
central bank actions themselves in the PTM
video series because these will change
over time.
What's important to understand here is the
implications.
This is what's going to stand the test of
time in your overall trading framework.
So you can apply this template at any
moment in time to any macroeconomic
conditions.
So you're probably wondering what is the
difference between nominal and real
interest rates.
Well, distinguishing between the two is
very important.
And it's at the core of any interest rate
decision or central bank agenda.
The real interest rate is simply the
nominal interest rate minus the level of
inflation.
In simple terms, real interest rates mean
everything for asset allocation in the
financial markets and the investment
decisions of entities like pension funds,
mutual funds, hedge funds, everyone on the
professional side.
And nominal interest rates themselves mean
very little.
Why is this?
Well, let's say the official rate is 5%
again.
What does a 5% official interest rate
return in a period of 5% inflation?
Well, in real terms, zero.
So in the United States, we adjust for
CPI, the consumer price index, which is
the level of inflation.
We adjust for CPI and in other countries
around the world, all you have to do is
adjust the official rate by the official
rate of inflation in that particular
country.
Now, what we're going to look at to get a
sense of how important real interest rates
actually are.
Let's have a look at this visually and
have a look at real interest rates
compared to the level of the stock market
and stock market valuation.
So if you look at this chart on the screen
here, you'll see in the bottom left-hand
corner, you'll see a key and there's three
variables here.
There's three lines on the chart.
Have a look at the key in the bottom
left-hand corner.
At the very bottom and denoted in pink on
the chart, we have the last price of the
real 10-year yield.
So the nominal level of interest rates
minus inflation.
So the official rate minus CPI.
And if we just cast our eye onto the
chart, if you just have a look at the pink
line and just look in the middle of the
chart.
So around 2010, 2011, you'll see that the
real interest rate in the US was around
two to two and a half around this level.
So the nominal rates adjusted for
inflation, the real interest rate in the
US, 2010, 2011, denoted by that pink line
around two to two and a half.
Then we just see a big move down.
And it goes negative.
It goes below the zero band.
So we have negative real interest rates.
And you can see the effect that that
started to have on the white line and the
green line, which if you look back to the
key in the bottom left-hand corner, is the
price of the stock market, the S&P 500
index.
And the green line, which is the actual
valuation of stocks.
So the price earnings ratio of the S&P
500.
And if you look back at the pink line, the
pink line did a bit of work, kind of
moving sideways between slightly below the
zero band up to 1% on a few occasions in
the last decade.
And then in 2020, boom, it goes negative.
Okay.
So, how does that affect the stock market
and how does that affect the price
earnings ratio of the stock market?
Well, you can see on the chart in the last
couple of years, you can see that the
stock market and valuations have gone
through the roof.
And that is essentially Fed policy being
accommodative to expansion and maintaining
expansion and high stock market levels and
high stock market valuations.
So, you can see the green line, where the
green line and the white line kind of come
together on the chart.
You'll see that that level for the P ratio
for the S&P 500 is around 30.
And then the dashed line is the forward P
estimate.
So, that's coming out in 2021 at 22.85.
But that's just a forecast.
And if you look at the reported data of
2020, we see the price earnings ratio of
the S&P 500.
When the S&P was around 3700, we see the P
ratio of around 30, which is obviously
extremely elevated in terms of valuation.
But let's have a look at this in slightly
closer detail.
If we look at US 10-year real interest
rates, so adjusted, nominal rates adjusted
for CPI, we've charted this against the
VIX, which we'll come on to later.
But you can see if you look at interest
rates in 2019, real interest rates in
2019, and you're looking at the right-hand
axis here on the chart.
So, the right-hand axis denotes the real
10-year yield.
So, the nominal yield adjusted for CPI in
the US.
You can see in 2019, we just see the real
interest rate in the US collapsing, and in
2020, going negative.
So, you can see how the real interest
rate, how important it is, how it affects
stock market level and stock market
valuation.
But one of the macroeconomic implications
here, well, real interest rates, whether
it's market rates, official rates, they
represent the real price or cost of money.
All things being equal, if money is
cheaper, market participants will borrow
more of it.
And when it's expensive, they will borrow
less of it.
So, let's get this down.
Relatively cheaper money causes more
borrowing, more liquidity, and
inflationary conditions and expansionary
GDP.
Relatively expensive money creates less
borrowing, less liquidity, and
deflationary conditions, and
contractionary GDP.
And listen, central banks know this,
they're not stupid, okay?
Central banks are looking at the same
things that we are looking at.
They're continually looking to manipulate
the supply of funds, which is real
interest rates, via the interest rate
mechanism, setting official interest
rates, or even doing abnormal policy, such
as intervening in the bond markets to
affect market rates.
So, incidentally, and I said we would come
on to this a little bit later, in terms of
the VIX and looking at real interest rates
compared to the VIX, you'll find that
relatively cheaper money, so lower real
rates, is going to create less equity
volatility because liquidity is higher.
And relatively expensive money creates
more equity volatility, because there's
less liquidity.
So, putting all this together, it stands
to reason that we can use real interest
rates in the US as a leading indicator to
equity market forecasts.
So, the level of the market and the
valuation of the market, and also the
direction and the volatility of the stock
market.
Now, what we're going to look at moving on
is the relationship between short-term and
long-term money.
So, the price of money in the short-term
relative to the long-term, okay?
So, this is basically yield curve
analysis.
So, we're looking at something called the
yield curve.
Now, what you're going to find in the
downloads area of this video, you're going
to find a couple of spreadsheets, which
are pretty big.
But you should definitely download them,
open them up, and start playing with them.
You'll see we've got one called benchmark
yields US and benchmark yields rest of the
world.
And you're going to find all of this
analysis that we're going to go through in
those spreadsheets.
But first, let's talk about some basic
bond relationships.
Firstly, and this should have started to
become quite obvious to you at this stage.
The price of a bond is inversely
correlated to its yield.
So, if demand for bonds increases, so
there's more buyers than sellers, the
bonds price will rise and the yield of
that bond will fall.
And the reverse is true.
Now, what does a yield curve do?
Well, a yield curve plots the interest
rates of bonds of an issuer that have
equal credit at different maturities.
The yield curve of the US government's
bonds plots the yields of differing US
Treasury bond maturities that have been
issued by the US government.
And we know what it's used for.
The money is borrowed and used to finance
public spending.
But we can actually plot the yield curve
and look at this visually.
So, we look at the US government Treasury
yields at different maturities and we
literally plot the yield curve.
So, here, and you'll notice this analysis
in the spreadsheet that you download in
the downloads area.
Here, we're plotting two yield curves at
two different moments in time.
So, first of all, we're looking at, most
recently, what the yield curve looked at
on the 3rd of January 2021.
And this is the blue line, okay?
And we can see across the bottom, we've
got the Fed funds rate, the official rate.
And we have different maturities across
the curve.
So, we have short term, so we have one
month, three month, six month, one year,
two year.
And then we have, all the way to the right
hand side, longer term rates.
We have the 10 year and the 20 year.
And then we have everything else in
between.
So, medium term rates, three year, five
year, seven year.
And we can see from the blue line, if we
take a snapshot of what the yield curve
looked like on the 3rd of January 2021,
we have an upward sloping curve.
We also took the data from the 8th of
November 2015.
And we plot that yield curve as well
across the maturities.
And we can see on the 8th of November
2015, we had an upward sloping yield
curve.
So, how does this actually work and what
does it all mean?
Well, the chart that you've just seen,
plots the yields on differing US
Government Treasury bonds from two
different dates.
The yield curve is dynamic and it changes
every day, okay?
So, that yield curve will look different
next week.
It will look different in a month's time.
The rates are changing dynamically, okay?
If we take a snapshot at any one point in
time, the demand and supply of bonds, so
therefore yields, by the market changes
because of expectations of both short term
and longer term rates.
And those expectations are based on the
market's economic projections of growth
and central bank policy.
Now, there's three different types of
yield curve.
Three different shapes of the yield curve
that represent conditions, okay?
Firstly, we have a normal yield curve.
Second, a flat yield curve.
And third, we have an inverted yield
curve.
So, we're going to go through these and
show you what it all means and how you can
use the yield curve as a leading
indicator.
So, what is a normal yield curve?
Well, it's what you just saw on the
screen.
It's an upward sloping yield curve.
It's where longer term rates are higher
than shorter term rates.
And most of the time, and this is why we
call it a normal yield curve, most of the
time, what you're going to find is the
yield curve is upward sloping.
That's because in normal economic
conditions, we have economic expansion.
This occurs most of the time.
During that time, the market demands a
higher interest rate, so yield, when
lending money to an issuer longer term due
to the risk of time, okay?
In a normal market, the longer time an
investor's money is tied up, the higher
the yield they're going to demand.
And most importantly, an upward sloping
yield curve signifies an expectation by
the market of future economic expansion.
So, on a relative basis, what does this
actually suggest?
Well, a normal yield curve, so an upward
sloping curve, suggests that investors, on
a relative basis, are selling longer term
bonds.
So, there's higher rates, okay, to buy
shorter term bonds.
And because of the buying, there's lower
rates, okay?
So, there's two main reasons for this.
So, firstly, buying short term bonds.
Well, if investors are expecting an
economic expansion, they don't want their
money tied up, long term, in low yielding
assets.
What do they want to be doing if they're
expecting economic expansion?
They want to buy risk assets, like
equities, and they have a preference for
shorter term liquidity.
And what's happening on the other side of
the curve, in long term bonds, on a
relative basis?
Well, investors, because they have a
preference for shorter term liquidity, in
an expected expansionary phase, they are
selling long term bonds on a relative
basis, okay?
They can park their money in shorter term
bonds, and later, they can buy back their
longer term bonds at a lower price.
So, a higher bond yield.
Later, in the future, they can do that
when they expect an economic expansion is
coming to an end.
So, they would actually take the opposite
action when they expect that the expansion
is ending.
They would sell short term bonds and buy
long term bonds at a lower price and
higher bond yield.
That's what they're doing with their
money.
They're shifting their money out of long
term bonds and into short term bonds, so
they can have a shorter term liquidity and
a preference for that to enable them to
take advantage of the expansion and to
park their money in risk assets, like in
the stock market.
And then later, when they expect the
economic expansion to come to an end, they
are forecasting that bond prices will be
lower and yields will be higher, and then
they take the opposite action.
They sell short term bonds and buy long
term bonds and get a higher yield on the
long term bonds.
So, to break this down, when investors
expect economic expansion, what happens to
the yield curve?
The yield curve steepens.
When they expect economic contraction, the
yield curve flattens or inverts.
So, when investors are expecting economic
expansion, what is happening?
They're selling long term bonds to buy
short term bonds.
What does that mean?
Well, we're getting higher yields on
longer term bonds and lower yields in the
market on short term bonds.
So, the curve, the yield curve is
steepening, okay?
And then what happens in the opposite
situation when economic contraction is
occurring?
Well, we're now doing the opposite, okay?
The market is selling short term bonds to
buy long term bonds.
They're putting their money into longer
term bonds because they expect a
contraction is going to happen.
And the more long term bonds that the
market buys and the more short term bonds
that they sell, what's going to happen?
Well, long term yields are going to go up
and short term yields are going to go
down.
And on a relative basis, this means that
the yield curve is going to flatten and
potentially invert.
Inversion is when short term rates are
higher than long term rates.
So, a normal yield curve happens most of
the time because economic expansion is
occurring.
And economic expansion, that is the
condition that is occurring most of the
time in normal economic conditions.
And of course, occasionally, we have
economic contraction in the economy.
And that creates an abnormal situation in
the yield curve where we have a flat yield
curve occurring and also sometimes
inversion.
Now, we saw a normal yield curve earlier.
What we've done here, we've put on the
chart, utilising the spreadsheets from the
downloads area.
We've put on the chart two normal looking
yield curve from two moments in history.
We've got the blue line from December
2020, which looks fairly normal.
And you can see that rates overall are
lower compared to January 2003, where we
plot the yield curve at that moment in
time.
And we have a normal yield curve there as
well.
So, what we're looking at here is two
moments in time where there was a normal
yield curve.
And you can see at the bottom of the
screen two sliders that are in the
spreadsheet in the downloads area.
And you can play with these sliders.
You can plot yield curves from different
moments in time.
And even at similar moments in time, you
can move the slider using the arrows and
compare two curves when they, for example,
go from normal to flat to inverting and
then back again.
So, inverting flat to normal.
And that's typically around when economic
expansions become contractions and
contractions turn into expansions.
It's a very useful thing to do.
Just go back in time and have a look at
different moments in time and plot the
yield curves.
It's actually fun and it's a good lesson
in economic history.
And, of course, a good lesson in financial
markets history.
So, let's have a look at a nice lesson in
financial markets history here where we
have a look at a yield curve that's
actually in the process of inverting.
So, we've got two lines on the chart that
we've taken from two moments in time where
we're plotting the yield curve.
And the two moments in time that we're
plotting is November 2019 and February
2020.
So, this is essentially going into the
COVID era when the markets got hit in
February 2020 and got smashed in March
2020 very, very aggressively where the
stock market went down a lot.
Okay.
So, if we look on the bottom of the chart,
we can see the Fed Fund's official rates.
And we can see the maturities from one
month out to 20 years.
And what we're interested in here is
looking at inversion occurring.
Okay.
So, if we look at the yield curve on the
right-hand side, you will see the rates
plotted in a table where the Fed Fund's
rate in November 2019 was 1.55.
And you can see looking down through the
table from one month to 20 years that the
numbers just get higher and higher.
Okay.
That is the characteristic of a normal
yield curve.
And that's plotted on the chart in orange.
Now, let's have a look in the table on the
right-hand side at February 2, 2020, where
the Fed Fund's rate was 1.59.
If we look at the 10-year at that moment
in time, we can see the 10-year yield is
1.51.
And if we look at short-term rates, so we
look at one month, it's 1.56, which is
obviously higher than 1.51.
Three months, 1.55.
Six months, 1.54.
And then the one year is 1.45.
Okay.
So what we see here is in the short end of
the market, 1-month, 3-month and 6-month
money, the yield is trading higher than
the 10-year.
So what's interesting is in terms of the
price action, is that if we compare the
short-term rates of 1-month, 3-month,
6-month,
on February 2, 2020 to November 10, 2019,
we can see that they're fairly similar.
But when we compare the 10-year, which was
1.94 on November 10, 2019, by Feb 2, 2020,
it was 1.51.
So what is being characterised in this
market is very obviously buying of
long-term bonds, which is suppressing the
yield and the yield is going down on the
10-year.
So on a relative basis, longer-term yields
have gone lower because of buying in the
market of long-term bonds.
So what's the market telling you here?
Well, the market is telling you that
between the period November 10, 2019 and
February 2, 2020, that there was a
preference in the market to buy long-term
bonds.
And during that period from November 10,
2019 to February 2, 2020, what would have
been happening?
Well, the yield curve will have been
flattening and then in the process of
inverting.
So the market was sending us a very strong
signal before COVID hit and had its
biggest impact at the end of February 2020
and March 2020 and even in April.
So the market was sending us the market
was sending us the message that they were
expecting economic contraction and the
yield curve was in the process of
inverting before it happened.
Now, in terms of market benchmarks and
reliability of using the yield curve as an
indicator or even better as a leading
indicator to economic expansion and
contraction.
The market, in terms of benchmarks,
gravitates to and uses the tens minus two
spread, meaning if we look at the 10-year
and the two-year price of money.
So in the chart, for example, we're
looking at 151 and 133 when we take the
snapshot on February 2, 2020, the market
uses this, the tens minus twos as an
anchor, as a benchmark, as an indicator
for economic contraction.
So the potential for recession, two
negative quarters of GDP growth.
And it's interesting that at this moment
in time, we can see that the yield curve
is in the process of inverting.
But it's inverting on February 2, 2020,
only in the very short end of the curve.
As an exercise, what you can do is go into
the spreadsheet in the downloads area and
play with the slider and take yourself
back to February 2, 2020, and then move
forward week by week.
And you can see whether or not the tens
minus twos spread actually went negative.
What do we mean by that?
Well, meaning that the 10-year minus the
two-year was less than zero.
That being the two-year was higher than
the 10-year yield.
So you can do that in your own time.
And also, of course, look at all economic
expansions and contractions in the past
and have a look at what the yield curve
actually did and have a look at what the
tens minus twos actually did.
We can actually chart the tens minus twos
and have a look at moments in history and
learn some important information about
macroeconomics in the past and financial
markets history.
So if we look back here in 2019, for
example, so we go back a little bit
further than we were looking at on the
chart on the previous slide.
We can see that in 2019, we can see that
in 2019, earlier in the year, what was
happening?
Well, you can see in the summer of 2019,
the yield curve, the tens minus twos began
to invert.
And it actually went to the zero bound,
the tens minus twos went to the zero
bound, which means the yield on the
two-year was the same as the 10-year.
And then later in the year, it actually
steepened.
The curve actually steepened where
relatively 10-year rates were higher than
two-year rates.
But what's interesting about this is that
it never went negative.
That's an important moment in financial
markets history.
And we'll come on to that a little bit
later.
But what the bond market was telling us
here at this moment in time, summer 2019,
was that the US economy was expected to
slow down and possibly contract and be in
trouble.
Now, we can even compare this moment in
time, going way, way back to previous
contractions.
So on the right-hand side here, you can
see, we've got the 2019 period, where
we've highlighted the moment in summer
2019, where the tens minus twos went to
the zero bound.
So 10-year and two-year yields were
basically the same.
And we've highlighted going way back to
the 2006-07 period that preceded the
global financial crisis.
You can see in the 2006-2007 period, in
2006, the tens minus twos went below the
zero bound, meaning two-year yields were
higher than 10-year yields.
And of course, they went positive, we can
see that visually on the chart in 2006 at
a period of time.
But for most of 2006, and a good portion
of 2007, the tens minus twos was actually
negative.
The spread was negative, below the zero
bound, indicating that the market is
expecting significant contraction in the
US economy.
And then, of course, what did we get?
Following that, in the second half of 2007
and all of 2008, we had economic recession
and financial markets collapse.
We had a liquidity crisis.
So what did we get in 2019?
Well, the Fed's not stupid.
They were looking at the same things that
everyone else was looking at in the
markets, what we were looking at.
They could see what the market was
expecting in terms of potential economic
contraction because of their preference
for long-term bonds over short-term bonds.
They could see what was happening in the
US economy.
They could see a slowdown occurring and
they decided to take action.
In the summer of 2019, they were active in
the market in lowering nominal rates,
increasing liquidity in the bond market
and therefore increasing liquidity in risk
assets and lowering volatility in the
equities market.
So a good six months, seven months before
COVID, the US economy was arguably in
trouble.
The Fed's actions in the summer of 2019
arguably saved the market.
And obviously, the market in the bond
market, the yield curve started to
steepen.
And we can see that on the chart in late
2019 when the yield curve started to
steepen and go more positive.
And arguably, it was COVID that actually
sent the US economy, the exogenous shock
of COVID sent the US economy into a
tailspin.
By no means am I saying here that the US
economy was, open quotes, fixed, close
quotes.
But a potential crisis that was occurring
in the summer of 2019 was averted by the
Fed actions.
And it was actually expected.
It was an expected move by the Fed.
We'll get onto this a little bit later.
But you've got to remember, the Fed is
looking at the same things that we look
at.
They're not stupid.
They're looking at the tens minus twos.
They're looking at the yield curve.
They're looking at the relationship
between short and long term money and what
signals the market is sending.
And the Fed tends to act accordingly.
But we'll come onto this later in terms of
Fed policy.
But it's just interesting to look at these
things and look at moments in financial
markets history to not only understand the
signals that the bond market sends as a
potential leading indicator to our
expectations of economic expansion and
contraction.
It's important to understand economic
history and financial markets history just
to have a foundational awareness for our
macroeconomic learning from macroeconomic
understanding of the world.
So why don't we have a look, for example,
at this moment in history during the 2005
to 2007 period.
We know that in 2006, 2007, that the tens
minus twos was negative below the zero
bound.
But what did things look like in 2005
compared to 2006?
Well, we've charted this using the
spreadsheet tool that you have in the
downloads area.
If we look at the orange line, we can see
we've taken a snapshot of the yield curve
on the 24th of July, 2005.
At the time, the Fed funds rate was 325.
And you can see across the curve, across
the maturities, we've got a pretty normal
looking yield curve.
Okay.
Fast forward to December 2006, 24th of
December 2006, the blue line.
What have we got here?
Well, Fed funds rate is now higher at 524.
And we've now got an inverted yield curve.
So if we look across the maturities, we've
got the 10 year at 463.
What maturities are higher than 463?
Well, we can look from one month, three
month, six month, to one year, two year,
and three year.
So we can see that the tens minus twos
inverts.
And basically the yield curve from one
month up to three years was inverted
relative to the 10 year.
So it's interesting to look at these
things throughout financial markets
history.
And I'd encourage you to keep doing it and
keep using that spreadsheet tool to really
get a foundational understanding of
macroeconomic history and financial
markets history.
It really helps.
So in terms of inverting, inverted yield
curves, what is it?
Let's get this down.
In inverted yield curves.
It's when the yield on bonds with shorter
maturity are higher than yields on bonds
that have a longer maturity.
It's an abnormal situation that occurs in
the minority of times.
This situation signals from the bond
market expected financial stress and an
impending slowdown in GDP growth with
possible GDP contraction.
So negative real GDP.
And it could indicate possible recession,
which we know is defined as two
consecutive quarters of negative GDP
growth.
So what is the market actually doing here?
Well, they're selling short term bonds and
buying long term bonds.
Let's start with selling short term bonds.
What is happening?
Well, the selling of short term bonds
creates higher yields in the short term,
in the short end of the curve relative to
the longer term, where buying of long term
bonds is occurring.
So we're selling short term bonds.
We get higher yields.
When a yield curve inverts, it's because
investors have lost confidence in the
economy in the short term.
They are demanding more yield for a short
term investment than for a long term one.
And what are they doing with risk assets?
They're selling risk assets like equities
as well, raising the money and they're
using that money to own long term bonds at
lower yields.
So they are selling short term bonds.
And they're selling risk assets and
raising money and putting that money and
parking it in long term bonds where
they're getting lower yields.
They are happy to tie up their money for
years even though they're receiving lower
yields versus short term bonds.
Why would they do this?
Well, they would only do it if they expect
economic conditions in the short term, in
the near term are going to deteriorate
materially.
So, causing risk assets like equities to
experience contraction for financial
markets to go down, for earnings of
companies in the stock market to go down
or collapse.
So, an inverted yield curve historically
is a signal, it's a warning sign that the
market is expecting potential economic
slowdown, potential financial markets
collapse from earnings contraction and
potential collapse.
So, we can obviously, again, use this
information as a potential leading
indicator to risk assets, equities, i.e.
the stock market.
Remember guys, we do live in a dynamic
world.
We don't live in a world where, for
example, the yield curve is normal for a
long time and then it suddenly inverts and
there's two polar opposite situations.
We obviously have a period in between.
We have what we call a transition period.
So, this is when yield curves go flat.
So, they can go from being normal,
positive and upward sloping to flat and
then inverting.
Or they can go from inverted to flat and
then normal, positive, upward sloping.
So, we've got some examples here of a flat
yield curve where we're basically at
moments in time in a transitionary period.
So, if we look at the orange line, that is
on the 17th of February 2019.
We know what happened later in 2019.
The yield curve was threatening to invert.
The tens minus twos was threatening to
invert and the Fed took action.
So, back in 2018, when we had a positive
upward sloping curve, the yield curve
began transitioning.
And in early 2019 and going into the
spring of 2019, we essentially had a flat
yield curve.
So, if you look across the maturities, you
can see the Fed fund rates, the official
rate is 2.4.
And you can see across the maturities, one
month money, 2.43.
Same for three-month money, six-month
money, 2.5.
One year, around 2.5, 2.55.
We're around 2.50, 2.55, all the way up to
five-year money.
And then seven-year money and 10-year
money is on a slight premium.
But essentially, the yield curve is flat
and in transition because we know what
happened later in 2019.
The yield curve, the tens minus twos,
almost went below the zero bound.
Then in the summer of 2019, the Fed cut
interest rates, cut nominal rates.
The official rate was going lower.
And by January 2020, where we can see on
the blue line now, we know that the tens
minus twos was positive.
And the yield curve was moving from a
slightly inverted yield curve, but the
tens minus twos not being inverted.
It was short-term rates.
So, one month, two month, and three month
money at a premium to the 10-year.
But two-year money was not at a premium.
So, the tens minus twos was actually
positive by January 2020.
And the yield curve was in transition
going from slightly inverted to flat to
going into positive territory.
And then returning to a more normal
situation of economic expansion and an
upward, positively sloped normal yield
curve.
So, a flat yield curve, how do we read it?
Well, a flat yield curve is characterized
as a potential transitioning period from a
normal yield curve to inverted, an
abnormal yield curve.
So, when the economy is transitioning from
expansion to slowdown, or even contraction
and potential recession, yields on
longer-term bonds tend to fall relative to
shorter-term bonds, which typically rise
on a relative basis.
Investors are engaging in an action of
purchasing long-term bonds relative to
short-term bonds and risk assets like
equities, where they're actually selling.
So, when we're transitioning from
expansion to contraction, we have a flat
yield curve, but it is in the process of
inverting.
When the reverse happens, so when an
economy is expected to come out of
contraction or slowdown and move into
expansion, investors engage in a relative
purchase of short-term bonds.
So, buying short-term bonds and risk
assets like equities and selling long-term
bonds.
So, in that situation, when we're moving
from economic contraction to expansion, we
have a flat yield curve, but it's in the
process of steepening.
So, it's pretty obvious we have to keep an
eye on the yield curve all the time as
traders and portfolio managers, but we
have to understand as well, we are not the
only people in the world looking at the
yield curve.
So, when we see a yield curve
transitioning and going from positive
upward sloping normal to going flat, guess
who else is watching it?
Yes, you guessed it.
The Federal Reserve.
The Federal Reserve sees this happening.
And in recent history, when these things
have happened, they are very accommodative
with their policies.
So, in the modern era with these policies,
so, lowering of short-term interest rates
via mechanisms like quantitative easing.
So, buying short-term bonds in the open
market.
As traders, we have to be very careful
because these actions distort the market
price mechanism of the US Treasury market
and all bonds that are priced off the
benchmarks.
The Fed is not stupid.
They see what you see and they act upon
it.
So, for example, in the previous chart
that we looked at, when we looked at the
line for February 2019, the market yield
curve was flat from six months to three
years.
But really, it was one month to three
And in the process of inverting, you
should use the spreadsheet and go back a
few months using the slider and see where
it came from.
But at the time, however, the economy and
the stock market didn't tank in 2019.
Why?
Because the Fed remained incredibly
accommodative.
And in Jan 2020, rates, as you can see,
were a full point lower.
It actually took the exogenous shock of
COVID in 2020 and global economic lockdown
to actually invert the yield curve.
So, have a look at the previous chart when
we're citing February 2020, when the
inversion actually started.
Even then, during that crazy time, the big
sell-off in markets with COVID in 2020,
even then, because we had record levels of
bond purchases from the Fed, the yield
curve actually went back into transition,
was flat, and then actually steepened in
2020 extremely aggressively.
And if we go back and have a look at our
chart that we looked at earlier, where we
plotted 10-year real interest rates, so
nominal adjusted for the consumer price
index, adjusted for inflation, the chart
where we had that plotted against the S&P
500 price, so the level of the S&P 500 and
the price earnings ratio of the S&P,
we can look at that.
We can look at that and just see what
happened in 2020.
We can see that real rates went negative.
And at the same time, if you look at early
2020 on the chart, where real rates were
negative, you can see that the S&P 500
after the COVID sell-off rallied.
And that was also because of additional
major quantitative easing at bond
purchases, suppressing short-term interest
rates in the market.
And then we had big multiple expansion
with the S&P 500 price earnings ratio.
But as we know, the Fed's accommodative
policies were in action in 2019 prior to
COVID.
What was actually happening there?
Well, nominal and real rates began moving
lower in the second quarter of 2019.
The nominal yield curve that we've been
looking at inverted in Q2, and the Fed cut
rates in July, September and October 2019.
The stock market performance in 2019, the
S&P 500 was actually up 30% that year.
The Fed basically remained accommodative
throughout 2019, and the market was
expecting this.
Hence, the move in the yield curve
anticipating it.
So, as a leading indicator, of course, the
yield curve is a good indicator of future
expansion and contraction.
But the Fed also sees this, and in recent
years has become much, much quicker
relative to previous business cycles at
reacting to it.
So much so that it can be said that in the
2009-2020 cycle, a transitioning yield
curve was indicative of the Fed's next
policy move.
Now, if you've ever heard the phrase, the
stock market is not the economy, this is
exactly what it means.
2019 was a good example of this, where
economic slowdown in the background was
occurring.
The signal was being sent via the bond
market, and the Fed could see it.
They were accommodative, they lowered
interest rates, and the stock market was
up 30%.
So, we do have to be careful here, guys.
Just because we see a normal yield curve
going flat and potentially inverting, we
don't want to be in a situation where we
get overly bearish and think everything's
going to collapse overnight.
Because it could be the case that the Fed
is simply going to step in.
So, just take that as a little warning.
We just want to be in a situation all the
time where we're flexible as traders and
understanding that in the real world, you
know, the Fed sees this too.
So, yes, we take this leading indicator as
a useful indicator to let us know what's
going on in the economy.
But we don't automatically think that it
must mean that the stock market has to go
down or even, in the other case, has to go
up.
It's not necessarily the case.
We have to be flexible enough to
understand that.
Now, let's go back to something that we
looked at earlier, where we looked at the
10-year real interest rate.
So, interest rates adjusted for inflation
versus the VIX, the S&P 500 volatility
index.
You can see from the chart, especially in
the last business cycle.
So, when we're looking, say, from the
period 2011 to 2020, what are we looking
at here?
Well, on the right-hand axis, you can see
that real rates are basically 1% or below,
and even at times negative.
So, below zero.
So, real rates being negative.
So, we see this in 2012.
We see it in 2016.
We also see it happening in 2019 and 2020.
So, what is happening here?
Well, when you compare this to the VIX,
which is in green, you can see for pretty
much the entire period, we have suppressed
volatility.
We have volatility trading in the low,
mid, and high teens.
And only on a few occasions does it really
go above 20.
So, for a very, very long period of time
in the last business cycle, so 2011 up
until 2020, before COVID occurred,
volatility in the equities market in the
S&P 500 was low.
It was low and consistently low.
Why?
Why was that?
Well, it comes down to the Fed's
accommodative policy of low interest rates
and quantitative easing measures.
This suppresses short-term rates in the
market, and essentially the Fed was
managing real interest rates to be below
1% and even negative at times.
What is that doing?
Well, it's increasing liquidity in the
financial markets and therefore reducing
volatility.
We learned this earlier that this occurs
relatively when we have periods of, in
history, when we have periods of low real
interest rates, so very low real interest
rates relative to history.
We get low volatility in risk assets
because liquidity is increased.
And in the reverse, if we get high real
interest rates relative to history, what
is happening?
Well, liquidity is going down and then
volatility is increasing.
So, when we're thinking of real interest
rates, so the 10-year real interest rate,
and thinking of the yield curve in the US,
we're not just thinking of it, these
leading indicators.
As indicators, we're not just thinking of
these leading indicators as indicators for
economic growth.
We are also thinking of these leading
indicators in terms of our projection, our
forward-looking expectation of liquidity
and health in the financial markets and
volatility.
So, let's tie all of this up together now.
It's obviously been a very, very long
video.
What have we done here?
Well, we've introduced you to how the
benchmark bond, the US Treasury market,
works in both absolute and relative value
terms versus equities.
Both the absolute and relative price or
cost of money have implications for money
flows in financial markets.
We've looked at nominal interest rates,
real interest rates, and the yield curve.
And taken together, real interest rates
and the yield curve do represent leading
indicators that tend to move before the
economy as a whole.
As in, before we get economic growth, and
they are indicators also of liquidity.
By just being on top of these indicators,
guys, we can predict to a large extent
GDP, earnings, and S&P 500 quarterly and
annual performance.
So, in a nutshell, the direction in which
the wind is blowing, the direction in
which growth is occurring, positive or
negative, and also the liquidity
environment.
And in the bigger picture, guys, knowing
which way the macroeconomic wind is
blowing and liquidity conditions in
financial markets is crucial to traders so
that we don't get caught in losing
positions when there's a shift in the
macro environment.
Macro is the bigger picture that affects
everything.
Real interest rates represent the
inflation-adjusted cost of money and can
be used as a leading indicator for our
future expectations of risk asset values
like equities, like the S&P 500.
The S&P 500, and for traders to
potentially act in the present in order to
benefit from future moves in financial
markets.
Moving on to the yield curve.
The yield curve represents the market's
expectation of short-term versus long-term
risk in the economy.
So, these are useful leading indicators to
traders, real interest rates and the yield
curve, but this comes with a warning, it
comes with a caveat.
Because due to the Fed actions that are
out there in real time in a dynamic world,
there is no rulebook here that states what
you have to do or must do in equities.
So, buying or selling when, for example,
you see short-term real rates rising or
falling versus long-term real rates
falling or rising, or even when the yield
curve is in transition.
Flattening or steepening, there is no
rulebook, because the Fed sees what we see
and can act on it and change the dynamic.
However, knowing what is going on is
absolutely crucial to your macroeconomic
understanding of what is going on in the
world at any moment in time, because we
have to have a macroeconomic view.
So, you use these indicators.
You can use these indicators and your
understanding of them in conjunction with
best practices in the equities market.
For example, when you see the VIX index in
transition, as we outlined in the
volatility videos in the IPLT video
series.
So, you use these indicators together.
You can use the VIX, you can use real
rates and the yield curve together to have
a much clearer understanding of the
macroeconomic picture at any one moment in
time, and have a macroeconomic view based
on these indicators.
Real rates and the yield curve are leading
indicators to economic expansion and
contraction, and also financial markets
risk and direction of risk asset
expectations, and even possible Fed
actions.
So, again, they're great indicators, but
we have to have a caveat on this.
The Fed can act.
The Fed is looking at what we are looking
at.
So, there is, unfortunately, no rulebook.
Now, what about bond products themselves
that are available to retail traders?
Well, Treasury bond products, they're few
and far between.
If we're going to speculate on the outcome
of bond markets by using bond products,
they are pretty limited.
As we outlined in the IPLT video series,
bond products like ETFs, they're extremely
limited in their volatility, and they
constitute a very small opportunity set.
They can't really be utilized by traders
for large amounts of trade ideas and,
therefore, consistent profitability.
From a retail trading perspective,
however, you can look at these products in
a couple of ways.
Firstly, as indicators themselves of
expansion and contraction, in addition to
utilizing real rates and the yield curve.
So, you can add this into your analysis.
You can use them in conjunction with real
rates at the yield curve.
Or, secondly, as either turbo hedges to
portfolios or very short-term directional
bets at economic turning points and
getting leverage through options.
To make shorter term bets.
So, what we mean by that turbo hedges is
basically calling a moment when economic
expansion is moving into contraction or
contraction moving into expansion and
using options to hedge a portfolio.
Or just taking very short-term directional
bets at those economic turning points and
getting a lot of leverage through options
to make shorter term bets.
So, there's the government bond products
there which are available at the link that
is on the page.
There's three main government bond ETFs,
which is the SHV, which is the short term
maturity, the SHY, so medium term, one to
three years, and the TRT, the 20 plus year
maturity.
Now, obviously, we're recording this at
the moment in time.
If products are delisted in the future and
or new products become available, just do
your homework yourself on each product.
What you have to do is make sure that they
are liquid and tradeable and have a very
active options market.
For international government bonds in
Europe, Japan, the UK, etc.
Just apply all the same principles that
you've learnt in this video.
Apply all the same principles to bond
markets around the world.
You need to take the same approach.
This is really, this video, a template
that can be transported and used in global
bond markets.
Just use this video as a template.
Okay, guys.
So, that was a long video.
It's a lot to take in.
Let's go back to the desk for a short
recap.
Okay, so welcome back to the desk.
Listen, I know that's a lot to take in so
early on in the video series, but it's
super important to be on top of real rates
and the yield curve.
You have all the resources now via the
downloads area to be able to update on a
regular basis your benchmark yields and
yield curve data.
You will be able to assess real rates in
the US and the shape of the yield curve
and changes that are occurring in both
real rates and the yield curve at any one
moment in time.
This is a super valuable resource.
It's going to be crucial to you for you
moving forward and forming your
macroeconomic view and therefore your
ability to predict GDP direction, stock
market direction, volatility and
liquidity.
Now, it will be worth you definitely going
over this video many, many times if you
are new to this, especially because
there's a lot to get your head around in
terms of relationships and why things
actually happen.
Also, remember the caveat so the Federal
Reserve, they look at the same things we
do.
They're always looking at the same things.
So, of course, we want to always have an
understanding and appreciation and know if
there's any changes in real rates and
changes in the yield curve.
And we need to be on top of them all the
time so we can get a gauge on the
direction of the stock market so we
position our portfolios properly.
However, as explained in the previous
video, there is no rulebook that says
exactly what you have to do at certain
times and when certain things happen.
We live in a dynamic world and policy
actions can change our views instantly.
Unfortunately, retail traders are always
looking for rulebooks or checklists or
shortcuts or they're always wanting to be
told exactly what to do by other people.
The best you can do if you're being
self-sustainable and you're actually
working towards becoming a pro level
trader.
The best you can do is just be on top of
the process and know what's going on and
act accordingly in your portfolios based
on a judgment call at the time.
Now, in this video, we learnt about
government or sovereign bonds, so when the
government borrows money from the private
sector.
In the next video, we're going to look at
the corporate bond market.
So when companies borrow money from the
private sector, and we're going to look at
how we can use corporate bonds in
aggregate as leading indicators to predict
the economy and therefore S&P 500 returns
as a whole, direction and returns of the
S&P 500.
So let's shoot straight into the next
video on corporate bonds and credit
spreads, and I'll see you at the end of
video five back at the desk.